[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 10 octobre
bienvenue dans cette édition du 7 8
journal sur tv 78 voici les titres de
l'actualité locale les des composteurs
distribués aux habitants de saint
quentin en yvelines depuis le début de
l'année l'agglomération en a remis 700
certains sont individuelles d'autres
collectifs comme dans une résidence à
montigny le bretonneux ou des voisins se
sont associés le gaming s'ouvre aux
personnes handicapées en joysticks et
une manette de jeu vidéo qui se
contrôlent entièrement par la bouche
elle fonctionne grâce au souffle à la
pression et via commande vocale un outil
développé par une entreprise d'elancourt
blue line et à
et puis rencontre avec julien baronne il
officie comme soigneur animalier au zoo
safari de thoiry une profession passion
exercé depuis peu suite à une
reconversion professionnelle c'est le
portrait de la semaine
et à suivre tout à l'heure une page
économique avec notamment la boutique
éphémère qui revient l'espace saint
quentin rencontre aussi avec l'un des
équipages du 20e raid amazones qui
débute demain et l'une de ses membres
nous vient des yvelines
[Musique]
réduire et trier ses déchets de façon
écologique c'est possible avec le
compostage à ce sujet l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise propose des
composteurs en format individuel ou
collectif des habitants sont venus l ai
cherchés récemment le reportage de manon
varaldo et de nicolas landry les
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
sont venus chercher leur composteur mis
à disposition par l'agglomération avec
un kit incluant un bio seau un tiers de
nos ordures peuvent être compostables
être acteurs de l'écologie une démarche
importante pour ses habitants
on s'aperçoit que le fait de de polluer
de consommer de plus en plus à des
impacts est vraiment significatif news
environnement je crois que ça y est il
est temps de trier ses déchets et de
mettre en place du compostage dans mon
jardin
lors de la remise du matériel des
conseils étaient transmis aux futurs
utilisateurs notamment sur les déchets
acceptés vous préparer une soupe il vous
reste des épluchures il vous reste des
vues du vert de poireau et les choses
comme ça tout ça vous pouvez le mettre
dans votre composteur la principale
précautions à prendre
ce sont les déchets d'origine animale on
la viande le poisson les corps gras tout
ça on conseille de ne pas le mettre dans
le composteur depuis février 2019 dans
l'agglomération 700 composteurs
individuels ont été distribués une
participation financière de 25 à 30
euros était demandé une démarche
également possible pour les quartiers et
résidences l'agglomération fournit le
matériel sans participation des
habitants
qu'est ce que tu nous apportes a fait
plus de concours
bon plus exotique à la résidence
l'arbalète des prêts à montigny le
bretonneux
un petit groupe de voisins s'est formé
pour accueillir trois bacs de compostage
de 800 litres une fois que le premier
bac le bac d'apport est plein on vient
dé verser la totalité dans le troisième
bac qui a le bac de maturation et
ensuite ça pourra servir aux espaces
verts à la pelouse ou aux gens qui ont
des bacs à fleurs par exemple les
résidents ont pu voir émerger la
transformation qui s'est faite entre ces
trois bacs mais aussi l'évolution de
leurs liens
maryline didier est tony se retrouvent
et échangent régulièrement autour du
compostage vecteur de lien social dans
la résidence il aurait pu être face à
face lors des prochaines élections
municipales
attrape les deux hommes feront
finalement front commun othman nasri
pourra compter sur une alliance avec
mustapha larbaoui l'ont annoncé
aujourd'hui le conseiller municipal
d'opposition avaient appelé la semaine
dernière le pharmacien et ancien
président du club de football à le
rejoindre pour le scrutin mustapha
larbaoui qui avait pensé un temps être
candidat avant de renoncer
il rejoint donc othman natrue qui reste
candidat principal dans une liste
commune nommée engagement trappe
citoyens et les propos sont recueillis
par marylène yapi shiloh c'est la main
tendue que j'attendais je vous cache pas
que
on est venu voir par ailleurs ce
malandain par exemple voilà mon choix
s'est porté maintenant sur la
candidature de othmane nasri et avec mon
groupe avec engagement trappe
nous travaillerons en ce sens et nous
apporterons les solutions nécessaires au
changement et à l'avenir de cette ville
est un rassemblement qui ne soit pas un
rassemblement partisan parce que
l'avenir de la vie d'aujourd'hui passent
pas par l'opposition entre la droite et
la gauche
il passe par un projet et puis passe par
des compétences et la compétence de
mustapha larbaoui elle est
incontournable et donc c'est
naturellement que j'ai proposé qu'on
fasse équipe qu'en forme un vrai duo un
vrai partenariat et les deux hommes
annonceront les grandes lignes de leur
programme
après les vacances de la toussaint a
noté 4 ap le maire divers gauche sortant
guy malandain a annoncé son souhait de
briguer un quatrième mandat en 2020 pas
de candidatures déclarées encore du côté
de l'adjoint ali rabais qui a lui
enregistré la semaine dernière le
soutien de benoît hamon
au chapitre économique le lancement de
la deuxième boutique éphémère scola
depuis le 2 octobre cette structure est
ouverte à l'espace saint quentin 20
stagiaires âgés de 18 à 30 ans voulait
apprendre les techniques de vente les
détails de nicolas landry deux créateurs
de vêtements à la boutique scola eric
fontanini et camille andrieu sont les
fondateurs d'habiles une marque créée en
octobre 2018
des vestes des salopettes ou des
tabliers avec des mains en activité
imprimer leurs particularités la
fabrication de pièces indémodables et
qu'en fait tu l'avais cela peut
supporter des deux côtés donc ça c'est
un argument de vente que vous pouvez
aussi expliquer ce nom vous confier
notre projet et que la vente à la fin
c'est l'essentiel non c'est créer mais
vous vous allez savoir vendre et nous
sans vous on sera pas faire donc c'est
ça aussi qu'il faut que vous disiez avec
habile c'est que notre projet il va
exister à travers vous et c'est ça qui
est important et c'est pour ça qu'on est
là et c'est pour ça qu'on est heureux de
participer au projet scola ces vêtements
seront à la disponibilité des vingt
stagiaires de la boutique éphémère
objectif pour revendre le plus de pièces
possibles
pourquoi commerce parce que j'aime
beaucoup le
le contact clientèle tous les jours ben
on a on a un nouveau challenge et c'est
ça qui est vraiment excellent je pense
que ce que la ram a apporté beaucoup
plus de connaissances les techniques de
vente comment conseiller les clients
comment aller plus loin dans la vente et
aux nouvelles expériences qu'on
renouvelle toujours avec les mêmes
objectifs développer le l'emploi local
et être vecteur de dynamisme économique
et de lien social
ces vingt jeunes âgés de 18 à 30 ans et
originaire de saint quentin en yvelines
vont être formés pendant deux mois au
métier de vendeur 24 heures de théorie
et 11 heures d'immersion dans la
boutique par semaine c'est aussi
l'accompagnement dans leur projet
professionnel et le développement du
savoir est et de la confiance en soi
ce jour là ça se passe avec aurélien
duarte champion de kick boxing et de
boxe thaï répète insiste quotidiennement
encre ton action dans la chair le
message c'est que chacun est responsable
de ce qui lui arrive et qu'on a un
pouvoir sur notre vie à la fin de la
carrière j'ai décidé de m'intéresser au
fonctionnement humain aux neurosciences
et j'ai pu mettre des mots enfin sur
comment je m'étais très en forme en
champions pour mieux partager
aujourd'hui plus de 75% des apprenants
de la boutique scola éditions 2018 ont
connu un retour à l'emploi après cette
formation est les zones commerciales
saint-quentinoise c'est le sujet du
prochain 7,8 écho au programme de
l'émission reportages au sein du
chantier opensky le centre commercial
elle doit ouvrir au premier semestre
2020 à plaisir un complexe de 31 mille
mètres carrés dont les travaux ont
démarré début 2017
et puis on parlera aussi de la réflexion
autour du pôle paris ouest forum givet
portes de chevreuse qui s'étend sur les
communes de maurepas et de coignières
une enquête en ligne a permis de
recueillir 2007 sans réponse entre mai
et juin
extraits on a voilà un taux de vacance
quête aux alentours de 5%
on a une problématique en termes aussi
de
de mobilité sur l'offre commerciale on
n'a pas un positionnement clair et on a
aussi des attentes des consommateurs sur
une volonté de mieux manger d'avoir plus
d'activités de mieux circuler au sein
même de ce pôle de trouver une cohérence
globale et de retravailler aussi
l'urbanisme qui est vieillissant
prochain 7,8 écho à retrouver demain à
vendredi à 18h30 sur tv 78 tout en
replay sur tv 78 points comme alors que
la paris games week a s'ouvre ce 30
octobre cette petite révolution a fait
son apparition dans le monde du jeu
vidéo andy joystick une manette qui se
contrôlent entièrement par la bouche le
souffle l'aspiration la pression est
aussi les commandes vocales l'appareil
permet à des personnes souffrant d'un
handicap lourd de pouvoir jouer par
exemple la fifa call of duty ou encore
forte night c'est une entreprise
d'elancourt qui a développé ce joystick
et pour en parler d'eux invités autour
de la table xavier corbin un bon soir au
directeur du développement à blue line
est acquis et spécialisée dans la
domotique 1 c'est-à-dire les objets
interconnectés et également florian
matra bonsoir chef de produit
spécifiquement sur sept ans dj si vous
nous expliquerez tout à l'heure comment
ça fonctionne voilà concrètement
première question pour vous xavier
corbin pourquoi avoir développé cette
solution va écouter chez glénat depuis
assez longtemps en offre des solutions
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap qui adressent principalement
les soucis de mobilité et
l'accessibilité la capacité de contrôler
son environnement
c'est à dire permettent un tétraplégique
d'allumer les lumières d'ouvrir sa porte
de répondre au téléphone et on s'est
aperçu qu'il y avait une grosse attente
également pour pouvoir accéder au
numérique ce que ce que nous ont fait
assez naturellement avec un joystick ou
une manette de jeu pour un tétraplégique
c'est évidemment bien plus compliqué et
c'est un des seuls et un des principal
loisirs auxquels ils peuvent accéder
donc on a développé cette manette en
dise au stick pour cet usage ni environ
50000 personnes tétraplégiques en france
important de leur donner cette capacité
de s'évader par le jeu vidéo par voilà
cet accès à un monde virtuel finale
devait absolument enfin on a en a parmi
nos clients pour exemple un jeune garçon
d'une dizaine d'années qui revivra monde
depuis qu'il a 7 cette manette de jeu
qui lui permet de jouer avec son frère
avec son père donc ça recréer du lien
social exactement du bien social et puis
devient réellement actif dans sa vie
quotidienne
et ça lui a même permis de développer
des capacités de respiration
d'inspiration et de musculation
également de la mâchoire
parce que la motivation est importante
pour un enfant de pouvoir jouer du coup
ils faisaient plus d'efforts qui
n'aurait pu faire avec
avec un argot thérapeute ou un autre
donc à un moment d'évasion ça développe
le lien social
je crois qu'il y aussi et forcément ça a
été démontrée le jeu vidéo a des
bienfaits aussi dans les soins vous
travaillé notamment avec des
établissements de santé via via cette
solution c'est ça absolument c'est
quelque chose qui est utilisé dans des
dans des centres de rééducation dans des
foyers d'accueil spécialisée parce que
c'est c'est un vrai loisir c'est un vrai
moment de liberté et d'évasion que l'on
va offrir à ces personnes là qui
aujourd'hui ont très très peu de moyens
d'interagir sur leur environnement pour
accéder à du loisir quelque chose de
plus fun on sait leur faire allumer une
lumière ou ouvrir une porte
mais ça c'est pour des gestes de la vie
quotidienne
là c'est davantage orientée sur le
plaisir c'est une manette qui fonctionne
grâce au souffle à l'aspiration aux
pressions aussi que l'on va exercer sur
cet appareil
il ya aussi le je crois de la commande
vocale qui qui rentrent en ligne de
compte
concrètement comment ça marche en allant
restant le plus pédagogique possible
comment ça marche cette solution alors
là donc j'ai le produit avec moins donc
en fait c'est un joystick buccale donc
là ici on va voir une pipette avec
plusieurs trous donc je vais pouvoir
souffler et aspiré dans chacun des trous
pour émuler une un bouton de man est
d'accord comme que typiquement je
souffle mieux pour appeler surcroît
j'aspire ça fait car et voilà et avec
cette base donc de jeu le joystick en
entier permet de faire bouger les bonnes
âmes donc en fait avec cette base là au
niveau de la bouche on peut aller
jusqu'à 26 actions différentes donc 26
touches ce qui émule largement une
manette de console aujourd'hui et ça va
permettre à la personne de pouvoir jouer
à n'importe quel type de jeux vidéo
juste avec la bouche et les comment
techniquement on arrive à transformer du
souffle voilà des mouvements en commande
en commande de manette
alors ça après c'est plus de
l'électronique ça se passe à l'intérieur
les gens c'est à l'intérieur en fait
avec des systèmes de membranes
on va avoir des pressions et tuyaux des
membranes qui vont se gonfle et se
dégonfle et ce qui va permettre de faire
un contact est trop électromagnétiques à
l'intérieur du boîtier qui va déclencher
derrière une commande est ce que c'est
un boîtier qui peut se régler ce
personnalisé selon les préférences de
chacun bien sûr les manettes
en général on a tendance aussi à changer
de touche voilà bien sûr tout à fait
donc en fait nous ce que nous faisons
que c'est que nous mettons déjà de base
des programmations à l'intérieur d'un
joystick d'une programmation de base
pour certains types de jeux donc jeux de
sport jeux de voitures jeu de
plates-formes jeu de combat est en fait
à partir de ses programmations
personnalisable le joueur a aussi les
possibilités dans le jeu de rechange et
ses touches d'accord à sa guise ça a été
long à mettre en place cette solution à
la développer
alors
c était ça après un petit moment où
effectivement hausse alors mention comme
le disait florian de créer quelque chose
qui soit universelle lui s'adapter à
toutes les plateformes qui soit facile à
configurer et également pour le joueur
et à pouvoir être utilisé par n'importe
qui est-ce qu'on peut jouer aujourd'hui
avec les principales consoles de salon
avec le pc ça peut être utilisé tout à
fait bien sûr en fait nous nous mettons
en avant pour le jeu mais on peut
également s'en servir sur un pc ou un
smartphone d'accord pour tout ce qui va
être sur un smartphone se servir des
applications et sur un pc traitement de
texte et navigation internet
mais tout ce qui s'en suit en fait ça va
et mulets tout simplement une souris et
quelques touches du clavier
donc après derrière on se sert de
l'ordinateur comme dans une souris et
donc les et tous les jeux ça marche avec
avec tous les jeux alors oui
effectivement ça marche avec tous les
jeux sur plusieurs types de plateformes
les consoles de salon notamment ps4 ps3
nintendo switch les pc le pour émuler
des souris windows mac os et également
les smartphones et de tablettes android
une dernière question avec vous xavier
corbin ça coûte quand même 1490 euros
est-ce que c'est pas un peu cher pour
l'attrait effectivement ça peut ça peut
paraître un peu cher et c'est d'ailleurs
un peu cher c'est vrai que c'est quand
même quelque chose à prix assez élevé
maintenant c'est une technologie
particulière ce sont ce type d'objet
vous imaginez bien c'est pas fabriquer
de même ordre de grandeur qu'un
smartphone ou qu'un équipement tel
qu'une télévision même un jeu vidéo
donc c'est une diffusion beaucoup plus
restreinte une fabrication en très
petite série
ce qui fait que ça va directement
impactés sur sur le prix mais on trouve
toutes les informations sur le site
internet de blue line et à merci flo et
matra merci xavier corbin directeur du
développement chez blue line et à merci
d'être passé en plateau est la chambre
des métiers et de l'artisanat des
yvelines accueillait aujourd'hui un
premier forum dédié au numérique le
public visé c'est les très petites
entreprises retour avec aurélie ronces
une vingtaine d'exposants réunis pour un
même but sensibiliser les petites
entreprises du territoire au numérique
un enjeu primordial aujourd'hui pour
mieux développer son activité
c'est ce qui a conduit la chambre de
métiers de l'artisanat des yvelines et
l'association france gestion a organisé
ce premier forum
l'évolution va très très vite
actuellement
et on a l'impression que les artistes ne
se rendent pas compte de l'utilité de
ces outils qui peuvent être très utiles
pour leur métier je fais de la
communication chez as it gets facebook
j'ai instagram je fais pas mal de choses
c'est j'avais besoin de voir si je
devais m'améliorer sur quel point je
devais travailler au programme de la
journée des ateliers des démonstrations
avec des casques de réalité virtuelle ou
encore des démonstrations de drones
c'est un outil qui est un objet un objet
connecté qui peut vraiment servir pour
nos entreprises
vous prenez l'exemple du bâtiment pour
faire des cartographies voir comment
elle cette déperdition de chaleur ou par
une centaine de tpe évinoise était
attendue la chambre des métiers de
l'artisanat des yvelines souhaite d'ores
et déjà pérenniser cette manifestation
[Musique]
soigneur animalier un métier qui
intéresse mais seulement trois écoles en
france prépare à ce métier être au
contact des animaux en extérieur c'est
le métier de julien baronne justement il
est âgé de 32 ans maintenant varaldo et
rodolphe blondel ont suivi au son
quotidien au zoo de thoiry
mathieu pour julien julien baronne 32
ans s'apprête ce matin à les donner à
manger aux lémuriens
là on est chez les makis cattas font des
lémuriens
mais ce que je fais généralement quand
j'arrive le matin c'est qu'on va
procéder à un premier nourrissage ça
nous permet de nous en tant que soigneur
de pouvoir regarder si tous les
individus du groupe vont bien
s'il n'a pas de blessure les lémuriens
mange des légumes le matin et des fruits
le soir le soigneur leur donne quelques
compléments alimentaires goût framboise
chaque il est attribué à une espèce sont
des loges qui sont chauffés à
l'intérieur ils ont à disposition de la
nourriture et de l'eau ils ont un accès
donc actuellement en pleine saison quand
il fait chaud on leur laisse ce qu'on
appelle un accès libre et quand les
températures vont commencer à baisser
puisque ce sont des animaux qui viennent
de madagascar ils n'ont pas forcément
l'habitude des températures très froides
hivernale le soigneur du soir sera
chargé lui de rentrer les individus
c'est pour ça donc du coup que à thoiry
on a une division on a les soigneurs du
matin et les soigneurs du soir
le soigneur muni de sa cisa et coupe des
branches de bambou pour une autre espèce
de lémurien
ce sont pour des lémuriens qui ont
l'habitude dans le milieu naturel de
consommer du bambou dont qu'ils adorent
ça ces lémuriens plus utilisés sont
abrités dans un second bâtiment de
caractère on les connaît parce qu'ils
sont très méfiants très peureux et du
coup et se méfie et sont en même temps
tentée par le monde
on essaye de les habituer à l'extérieur
80% du travail du soigneur animalier est
consacrée au nettoyage des enclos une
tâche en extérieur qu'ils apprécient
puisque avant d'être soigneurs
animaliers
il était assistant logistique dans un
entrepôt de fret aérien à roissy
c'est aussi ça le métier bon bah on va
c'est un métier qui est assez physique
on travaille à l'extérieur faut pas
avoir peur
l'hiver d'avoir froid et il était
d'avoir chaud c'est une reconversion
professionnelle pour julien il a
découvert ce métier à travers des
bénévolat j'étais je pense un peu âgés
pour faire les écoles du coup je me suis
tourné vers une formation à domicile qui
va en fait vous fournir les cours vous
êtes suivi par un professeur mais à
distance et qui va donc vous fournir
aussi des conventions pour les stages
c'est ce qui est super important chez
les soigneurs fait l'expérience
après plusieurs stages dans des parcs
julien a débuté comme soigneur au zoo de
thoiry en juin une reconversion
professionnelle bénéfique pour le
trentenaire
ça n'a pas été un chemin facile mais il
faut s'accrocher et fournit arrive il y
a deux équipe de soigneurs julien fait
partie de l'équipe du matin ils se
retrouvent avec sa collègue pour faire
le point sur leur jeu
mais le reste du temps le soigneur a
toujours son talkie walkie pour échanger
avec ses collègues ils sont particulier
parce que ce sont des talkie walkie qui
une fois allongé ont sonné et donc si on
a un incident quelque part dans le parc
et qu'on se retrouve au sol avec la
jambe cassée par exemple le tall qui va
sonner surtout chez tout le monde et
donc du coup ils peuvent nous retrouver
comme ça et ça ferait une alerte les
soigneurs s'occupent également des
animations les visiteurs prennent place
à bord du safari
on va donc accueillir les visiteurs les
faire monter dans le camion et partir
pour une petite heure et demie les
visiteurs peuvent découvrir des lions
des éléphants et d'autres animaux durant
cette visite en compagnie de julien en
france seulement trois écoles prépare au
métier de soigneur animalier une
aventure sportive et solidaire le 20e
raid amazones débute demain six jours de
trails run and bike canoë également à
tir à l'arc au vietnam et pour cette
édition des équipages venant des
yvelines seront en course
l'une des membres de cet équipage remis
fourni est avec nos plateaux bonsoir
vous êtes de carrières sous poissy vous
allez être vous dans l'équipage de faith
together donc c'est le nom de
l'association que vous avez créé pour ce
raid ça débute demain avec le départ le
départ pour le vietnam qu'elle est quel
est votre état d'esprit
un jour deux c'est déjà demain départ ça
fait bientôt un an qu'on prépare le raid
niveau sportif on cherche un partenaire
qu'on soutient l'association mille et un
sourires
donc on a du mal à réaliser tout ça mais
parlera du soutien à l'association mille
et un sourires dans un instant pourquoi
vous lancer dans cette aventure c'est
une première participation qu'est ce qui
vous a poussé à le faire
alors cette aventure j'ai avec ma soeur
on a 18 ans d'écart on
mais vécu ensemble et on avait envie de
vivre une autre aventure et le raid
amazones on a choisi sera delà parce que
c'est un vrai qu'il ya vraiment un
aspect solidaire qui était important
pour nous et qui donne tout son sens
or l aspect sportif as ps solidaire il
ya l'équipe organisatrice du raid qui
soutient chaque année une association
locale pour le coup ce serait une
association vietnamienne et vous vous
avez décidez vous nous l'avez dit de
soutenir mille et un sourires qui oeuvre
pour les enfants malades et handicapés
c'est ça ouais en fait ils accompagnent
les enfants malades et handicapés mais
aussi les familles dans leur quotidien
ils les soutiennent financièrement
matériellement et c'est vraiment une
asso qui nous touchent et
particulièrement avec qui on a des
contacts et et qu'on soutient tout au
long de notre préparation et aujourd'hui
on a la chance d'avoir boucler notre
budget dont tous les fonds qu'on
débloque maintenant c'est pour un budget
de combien pour faire cette aventure il
faut compter à peu près ça dépend le
nombre de participantes dans l'équipe
mais faut compter billets d'avion inclus
à peu près dix mille euros
je crois qu'on peut être 4 par équipage
s'est passé les équipes de deux le 2 2 3
2 2 ou de 3 ça vous tenait à coeur oui
desoutter particulièrement cette
association un sourire oui oui parce
qu'on cherchait une association avec
laquelle on pouvait avoir des liens on
pouvait
on pouvait avoir des rencontres un
partage vraiment et on a fait une course
avec un petit garçon malade et et pour
nous c'est vraiment important d'avoir
des contacts humains et pas seulement
l'aspect sportif
donc ça c'est pour le volet solidaire
forcément un volet sportif dix jours de
six jours pardon de traversée du vietnam
qu'est ce qui vous attend sur place
alors du run du canoë du vtt et aussi du
tir à l'arc et une chasse au trésor
vous êtes préparés vous avez dit de
longs mois sur le plan physique
en tout cas pour affronter web plus ou
moins bien selon les épreuves parce que
typiquement un canoë on peut pas en
faire tous les jours mais on a la chance
d'avoir des partenariats avec le raid
amazones avec la fédération française de
canoë de tir à l'arc
donc on a pu s'entraîner avec les clubs
locaux donc
donc on s'est préparé comme on a pu et
on fera au mieux qu'on peut pour tous
ceux qui nous soutiennent les
partenaires grâce à qui on peut partir
demain mais aussi nos proches et notre
famille qui nous soutient tous les jours
depuis depuis un an
au sud il faut être en bonne condition
physique et sur place il ya aussi
forcément des conditions météo un peu
difficile de l'humidité peut-être qui
vous attend c'est typiquement des
conditions auxquelles on ne peut pas
vraiment se préparer
ici donc c'est à peu près 30 degrés et
un taux d'humidité assez important avec
des averses et beaucoup de dénivelés
aussi donc ça reste d'être d'être
intense et du coup l'objectif pour vous
c'est de le boucler c'est participer à
l' aventure c'est ça qui compte d'abord
je pense que je vais pas parler au nom
de ma soeur mais pour moi l'objectif il
est déjà atteint en partie parce que
notre gros objectif en tout cas pour moi
c'était d'y aller et maintenant c'est
que du bonus
tous les fonds qu on va on va faire
notre maximum pour encore débloqué des
fonds pour mener un sourire et pour
faire honneur aux partenaires à nos
proches et notre famille sur place
on souhaite bonne chance pour ce raid
remis fournier participantes donc au 20e
un raid amazones avec l'équipe faith
together et on pourra suivre 88
l'équipage 88 on pourra suivre les
aventures du raid amazones sur le lien
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
et pour terminer ce journal on retrouve
mélanie poquet bonsoir de la rédaction
de tv 78 et pour votre coup de coeur
loisirs cette semaine mais la liste un
bond dans le passé que vous proposez oui
pantalons serrés blazer cintré mini jupe
imprimée déploie des rayures à
rambouillet on vit depuis un mois et les
années yéyé une manifestation organisée
par le lion's club de rambouillet et
pourquoi les années 70 vient vallée nous
donne la réponse
les années yéyé c'est des couleurs de la
bonne humeur et de la personnalité
on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que tout est
un peu dans un cx il faut que ce soit
héros dynamique partout dans tous les
sens et là on retourne dans la joie de
vivre de ses cette époque là et la joie
de vivre mélanie ça va se conjuguer avec
différentes animations les prochains
week-ends vont être bien remplie mais
celui ci dès samedi 12 octobre c'est
prévu une animation 6 6 13 italienne il
y aussi une vente aux enchères qui est
prévue le même jour là les passionnés
pourront peut-être s'offrir une camaro
des années 60 où une chevrolet des
animations au profit des oeuvres du
lion's club des précisions le slogan
c'est 60 jours d'animations sur les
années 60 pour les plus de 60 ans en
difficulté alors notamment les malades
d'alzheimer
vous savez que les lions ce club a lancé
les centres d'accueil de jour alzheimer
et ils nous en avons à rambouillet il
aura ensuite les personnes qui ont des
problèmes de vue un bibliothèque sonore
la vue qui baisse après 60 ans les
handicaps physiques et mentaux
alors la vente aux enchères est prévue à
14h à l'hôtel mercure de rambouillet
l'animation italienne elle c'est le
matin dans la galerie marchande du bel
air
merci mais la nier pour connaître
d'autres idées de sorties il ya plein
d'autres choses encore dans les yvelines
votre émission 7,8 loisirs et c'est à
retrouver dans quelques minutes sur tv
78 voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi belle soirée à
tous
[Musique]